I'm leaving money on the table and then
they think to themselves well I don't
want to fur that business out because
like they should get that from me and
then they try and glob that I need to do
this too as I can get more money on
every customer here's the thing the
biggest mistake that I see entrepreneurs
who are at you know 2 million three
million five million ish is that they
are trying to solve their business
growth Problem by just trying to glob as
many different things as they possibly
can and so then they just start coming
out with thing after thing after thing
after thing for that audience rather
than thinking maybe I should expand my
audience and keep selling the thing that
I'm really good at the thing that I'm
best at the thing that's the best
leverage for my opportunity my skill set
because the problem that we're trying to
solve is that we're trying to make more
money it's doing all these other things
it distracts from the core business
opportunity